let's begin with what you need to know
because i was so excited yesterday to
see the second chapter of the preseason
of cardinals quarterback kyler murray a
generational talent as he was described
earlier this week by cardinals gm steve
kim it did not look generational last
night three for eight
he was sacked a couple of times once for
a safety he was flagged twice for a
false start because he clapped too
abruptly he was too halting in his
clapping while he was trying to call for
the football it just was not a good
night for kyler murray and look not
every night was ever going to be a great
night for him he's going to have to deal
with some adversity big cat the
adversity came last night against the
raiders
i'm here to over overreact to some
preseason games with you mike i think
this is kyle murray being too short
anytime he has a bad game we're just
just
no but in honestly i i don't really care
about the preseason performances you
obviously want to see your quarterback
do well especially number one pick a guy
who everyone's like how's it going to
fit in the nfl uh but the spin zone is
three for eight is an homage to josh
rosen who took uh you know kylie murray
took his job that was a very josh
rosen-esque line and i i don't really
care how a quarterback looks or a guy
looks in pre-season ultimately it
doesn't really matter it's pre-season
what i do care about i don't know if you
caught the awkward interview he did on
the sideline where he was asked what his
goals were personal goals were for the
season and i think his quote was that's
that's uh where i keep those inside and
it was a very awkward moment and look
i'm not gonna beat up on a kid who's 21
22 uh and just coming to the nfl but
if you can't deal with the media
it's going to make your life a little
bit more difficult and we've seen it
with many quarterbacks where if they
can't if they can't give uh you know
good answers kyle murray had that dan
patrick interview that was very weird
super bowl week that's something he can
fix right away that football stuff will
come along he'll eventually get up to
game speed and i still am buying kyler
murray stock but the media stuff fix it
right now because it's not very hard to
just give answers and uh not have this
uncomfortableness every time you're on
camera
well and it doesn't happen every time
he's on camera but when he is naturally
uncomfortable it does come through and
last night he was uncomfortable because
he had a bad performance this is a guy
who has not encountered much football
adversity he got a dose of it last night
and even though it doesn't count it's
nationally televised you're out there
your pride's on the line and a week
after he passed the eyeball test and
that's all i'm looking for in the
preseason from a new player does he look
like he belongs on an nfl field he
looked like he belonged last week
against the chargers this week he didn't
look like he belonged and i think that's
what adds to discomfort and you're right
it was an awkward interview he didn't
make eye contact with lisa salters he
wouldn't look at the camera not that he
should look at the camera in that
setting but you could he just didn't
know what to do he was like all over the
place and and it he is only 22 he just
turned 22 and i think that he's going to
have to learn how to project when he
hits those moments of adversity how do
you project a calmness a confidence a
lack of discomfort and you're right
that's something he can control and he's
going to need reps to do it just like
he's going to need reps on the football
field let's hear from him after the game
he was asked to react to his performance
on thursday night here's what he had to
say
everybody felt ugly on the sideline
after you know the first four or four
drives or whatever it was but that's
just uh you know it's part of it
it's good for us to see that it's good
for us to feel that and uh you know
obviously like i said we're very vanilla
right now so
it's tough it's hard to judge but i
think when we get out there you know
we're ready to roll
yeah the problem is the offense has been
elevated also the defenses they're
facing are vanilla now i don't know
maybe john gruden the raiders head coach
loaded up a little something extra for
kyler murray because that was one of the
guys that gruden was believed to be
linked to and and and if he can knock
him down a peg maybe it looks better for
the raiders to have not gotten him i
don't know but i wouldn't be surprised
if i found out that john gruden
maybe added a little more game planning
to this one than you would ordinarily
see in a preseason game just to kind of
take a little bit of the steam out of
the kyler murray express well how about
this fact mike the cardinals are a
really really bad team they were the
first pick for a reason they were really
bad last year they will be bad again
this year so there will be times where
kyler murray will not look good and it
won't all be about kyler murray it will
be about his offensive line it will be
about the fact that he doesn't have a
ton of weapons out there so i i'm not i
do i i joke about how i overreact in the
preseason i get my practice in because i
like to overreact every single week but
i really don't care about kyler murray
not looking great last night it is his
second preseason game he's going to
figure it out he's got to figure out
both the football stuff and figuring out
a way to just do the canned answers that
really when you answer a question
athletes are great at it where they
answer a question but they haven't
really answered the question once he
gets that down he will be off and
running
yeah and i i am rooting for him i hope
he's going to be great but part of it is
going to be the reality that it's not
going to come as easily as it did in
high school and college where you just
show up and you dominate it's not going
to be that way at the next level and i
think he's starting to figure that out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports